I went to California State University
Monterey Bay right down the street in
Monterey and but the summer between
graduating high school and going to
college
I watched the rock which was a movie or
Sean Connery and Nicolas Cage and in
that they had feels the seals get shot
they get killed by the Marines but they
looked really cool you know they came in
and their little underwater vehicles and
I came out of a sewer with their
wetsuits and their their guns and I was
like those guys are badass and so I
started researching and reading about
the seals and everything I came across
was how their training was the toughest
in the military and they were the most
elite military unit so I wondered
something crossed my mind I wondered if
I could do that I said to myself do I
have what it takes to become one of them
so in high school I was on the football
team but I never started I tried out for
the basketball team I didn't I didn't
get picked up
I can't even say I got cut because I
just didn't get picked up and I so was I
did not have a stellar athletic career
in high school so then there was this
this physical endeavor of becoming a
seal and I was like well I should try
this and I told my parents I wanted to
do it and at first they were like you're
crazy just go to college do college so
he said okay so I stayed in college for
like two months and I dropped out and
said and I went to a recruiter and I
enlisted in the Navy and interestingly
that at that time I said to myself if I
don't do this now
I'll never do this and I'll always
wonder what happened what would have my
life been like well what my life be if I
did do that I didn't want to have any
regrets I didn't want to have I didn't
want to be 3040 years old thinking well
one day once I wanted to be a Navy SEAL
I needed to find out if I could do it
and I needed to do it then and actually
about that kind of that train of thought
has led me through a lot of things in
life like okay if I don't do this now
you might not ever do it or you might a
couple years down the road regret having
not tried or not gone for that or taking
a risk essentially so I took the risk
and drop that a high score call it and
enlisted on a few months later we
and my parents were really proud of me
at that point in the beginning they
weren't and then as I left and went
through the process and and I made it
through the training the training is six
months long and often times going
through it people get hurt or rolled
back for performance so you stay there
for a really long time but I was able to
make it through in one in one iteration
which was I was very fortunate and then
so my 20s that entire time I was
stationed mostly in Virginia that's the
phase of my life I don't talk much about
but it's really formative of Who I am
now and what I do now the the decade
twelve years that I was in the Navy and
I don't talk a lot about it because you
know we were the silent professional
that's how we were brought up we were
not supposed to talk about what we did
and I really took that to heart and I I
was raised in that community by guys who
were that I really respected that kind
of beat that mentality into you that hey
you're a Navy SEAL you're not supposed
to talk about what you do
[Music]
you